hey everyone i'm red mufflerman so last
week as of the recording of this video
netflix released rise of the teenage
mutant ninja turtles the movie and this
is a movie i've been anxiously waiting
for ever since i saw the series together
with a friend of mine over discord
during a quarantine but for a lot of you
out there there's a very high likelihood
that you saw this movie pop up and went
what
and for good reason the history of the
show is
troubled to say the least but i want to
talk about it for a bit because frankly
this show
banks
let's venture back to the magical year
of 2018 the world was greeted with the
release of super smash bros ultimate
avengers infinity war finally came out
and we were only one year away from a
massive apocalyptic nightmare and so we
had the premiere of rise of the tmnt on
july 20th 2018 and it was completely
different from any of the shows we had
before the turtles were really bad at
being ninjas they had magic weapons that
let them do all sorts of crazy [ __ ] like
opening portals or making yourself into
a giant energy kaiju in most of the
previous shows the visual designs were
always very rounded and uniform for the
turtles almost as if having them look
the same would make it easier to produce
toys but in rise each of the turtles
have their own unique look based on
different species of turtles raph is a
snapping turtle leo is a red-eared
slider turtle donnie is a softshell
turtle and he wears a little backpack to
hide his soft backside it's it's a cute
little detail and mikey is a box turtle
this does a lot to really give each
turtle their own visual look and it
really helps them stand out from each
other which helps a lot because visually
this show is [ __ ] insane
shots are animated in dynamic fashion
characters will be running towards the
camera in perspective with bombastic
explosions fluid and powerful motions
are animated with a stylistic master
stroke and just
it's so cool dude it's very reminiscent
of the type of animation you'd find in
anime like gurren lagann or promere and
when i was re-watching a few scenes to
prepare writing this
i found myself just squealing you can
tell the folks at flying bark are a
bunch of weebs and god i love them for
it ryze is also genuinely funny and well
written each of the turtles stand apart
really well from one another ranging
from leo's peter parker-esque jokiness
which is elevated by ben schwartz's
stellar performance who you might
remember as sonic the hedgehog
meow wrath is portrayed as this big
tough guy who wants to lead his brothers
down the path of being heroes
but also having this uncertainty about
himself where he's prone to cracking
under pressure i'm talking about my fear
stink mikey's a free-spirited little guy
that doesn't really like fighting he's
the artist of the family constantly
drawing making music and generally just
enjoying life as he goes how about we
let the artist of the crew take a poke
at it and then we have donny like always
he's the tech guy he's also a
narcissistic self-centered know-it-all
that has no respect for anyone around
him
i love him he's my favorite
you are not kidding are you oh and did i
mention the main antagonist is voiced by
john cena so
is this gonna hurt it will
if i'm doing it right
so incredible cast radical new ideas a
complete reimagining of the turtles with
gorgeous animation and a radically
stylized presentation the show was
poised to make a splash on nickelodeon
when it finally dropped and all the
turtles fans hated it
so yeah when i said the show was
completely different that apparently
didn't sit well with a lot of turtles
fans
raph isn't supposed to be the leader why
are they calling themselves the mad dogs
this show looks way too weird splinter
is a bad dad and okay yeah for the
record splinter in the show is kind of a
bad dad no
my butt is asleep just how i like it
there's a payoff to all of us i promise
but yeah a lot of turtles fans were uh
pretty vocal about their disdain for the
show's overall direction this radical
departure was a little too radical for a
lot of people but over time the show
really began to get a foothold with some
really dedicated fans that enjoyed what
ryze was trying to bring to the table
and then nickelodeon stepped in nick had
a lot of confidence in the show at first
upon its premiere they immediately
renewed it for a second 26 episode
season but as the first season
progressed that 26 episode order
went to 13. then the pragmatic overlords
at nick decided to move premieres of the
new episodes off of the main nickelodeon
network onto nicktoons which is a
premium channel service that mostly only
airs reruns of older shows so yeah the
turtles were essentially thrown into
nicktoons jail episodes weren't aired on
any sort of streaming services and nick
kind of just left this show to die
despite this season one did okay if you
at least look at the ratings for the
show on a premium channel but then we
skipped to 2019 the world went into
lockdown and oh boy the concurrent
viewership for this show on tv was
abysmal for the second season add on to
the fact that due to nick cutting the
episode count from 26 to 13 flying bark
had to cut a large swath of the content
they had planned meaning even episodes
that had been completely boarded and
ready to begin production just had to be
thrown out yet in spite of that
season two is some of the best moments
of anything i've seen from the turtles
the last episode in particular has one
of the greatest pieces of animation i've
ever seen and people started to take
notice scenes from the final episode
started to make the rounds on social
media and people started freaking out
how is it that a show this cool had
evaded their notice all this time
nickelodeon professional bag fumblers
and then we have the movie that was just
released and
[Laughter]
this
is great everything that's fantastic
about the ryze series is present here it
focuses on leo's personal journey having
to take responsibility to protect the
things that he loves
and realizing that no matter how tough
things in life get he can always rely on
those around him that the act of asking
for help isn't a weakness but the
greatest strength also casey jones
travels from the future to stop a kang
invasion and has a [ __ ] chainsaw
hockey stick and it's so
[ __ ] cool
but yeah i can't recommend rise of the
tmnt enough pull up netflix and give it
a watch is what i would say but
currently netflix only has the first
season and the movie netflix can't stop
taking l's dude so i'm gonna ask you
guys a favor watch the show in the movie
and really give it a shot i think it's
something that a lot of people will love
and then tell me what you think in the
comments and on social media with the
hashtag save rot tmnt this show is
really something special it has a style
and sincerity that i think really sets
it apart and honestly i hope you like it
as much as i do but if you like what we
do feel free to drop a like and
subscribe to the channel and if you like
me you can find me on twitch twitter and
youtube as redbufflerman and yeah i'll
see you later everybody take it easy